What's your background, Kennedy?
>> Hello, Sam. God bless, man. Uh, I live
in Iran and as you know, it is a very u
tough place to be a Christian. Well,
these mutag guys uh will literally
arrest and you if you commit apostasy.
Is my voice clear? I'm sorry.
>> Yes, it's clear. Yes, exactly.
>> All right. Well, uh the first question I
wanted to ask is uh how do I live in
this country and uh seek truth, seek uh
Christ as I cannot I literally cannot go
to the church.
>> Well, I'm just curious how are you on an
internet right now? I mean, aren't you
going to get in trouble?
>> No, no, no. I use a fake name and I
unfortunately cannot show my uh camera.
>> What about people in your house? Are
they not going to know what you're
doing?
>> No. My family is not a strict Muslim
type of family. They're really not into
it.
>> Okay. Well, you're asking me what should
you do? Well, what you should do is keep
praying, keep worshiping, keep
glorifying Jesus Christ, letting the
Lord know, which he already knows, that
though your desire is to go to church,
you're afraid you're going to be
arrested and killed, and that God will
make a way for you to escape, to go to
church, and God will take that into
consideration. The Lord knows
The Lord knows. He knows your situation.
It's not like you don't want to go to
church. It's, you know, if you go to
church, you may get caught and be in
prison, tortured, if not killed. So say,
Lord, you know my situation. Then I ask,
Lord, in your mercy, make a way of
escape so I can gather with your people
and be part of the church and do the
things you ask of me. And God is
patient, brother. God knows your heart
better than you do. Sadly, there are
people like us in America who can go to
church. We don't. Like my my
disease, having body dysmorphia. Satan
has been beating me for the last two
months because I don't like to go out
publicly because I don't like the way I
look and because I can only dress a
certain way. That has been used and God
forgive me to my shame. a sad excuse to
hinder me from getting to the sacraments
and hiding myself in my room to my
shame. So, I need deliverance. I pray
God doesn't punish me. So, isn't that
ironic? We have the freedom to go to
church here. We don't take the
opportunity. So, here's a guy that wants
to go to church, but he knows if he goes
goes, he may be killed. Ask the Lord to
make a way of escape.
That's it. Be patient and that's it. The
Lord's not going to damn you to hell.
I hope so. May grace of Christ be upon
us.
>> He knows.
>> Well, I had another question if you
don't mind. Uh I have a lot of of course
Muslim friends in Iran here and uh well
most of them are really easily uh
debunked with very simple arguments but
many of them being these Shia guys do
not even accept hadith as a part of
their faith. So it's not as easy for me
to debunk them with just sah bkari and
the stupid things in there. How do I use
Quran against them? How you think I
should?
>> There's too much Quran. You can just
show them from the Quran their problems
and even their own tradition they have
problems. For example, Mutah,
right? And not only that, besides the
fact that the Shia still do temporary
marriage prostitution, the statements
within the Quran itself that are
problematic, for example, to show them
some of the moral teaching of the Quran
is 424 where you can take a married
woman if she's a captive and then and
sell her off.
>> Well, you know what they say, man? They
say, "Well, the Quran is the word of
God. So, if this is what God said, it is
what God said."
>> Then, brother, then you can't argue with
that. If they are telling you this is
what God says, then you can't argue
against that. The only way you're going
to argue is to try to show them that the
Quran is not God's word.
>> Right. That's that's my question.
>> Yeah. But your question is when you show
them how can this be from God, they're
telling you it is from God. So then
you're going to have to find a different
way to show it's not from God. So then
you need to ask them what would convince
you this can't be from God.
H I see
>> what could what would convince you this
is not from God. They say nothing.
You're wasting your time. They say,
"Well, if you show me
that there are problems with the
teaching of the Quran," say, "Well, what
kind of problems?" When I showed you the
moral problems, you go, "No, well, God
said it. It can't be a problem."
See the point?
>> Yeah.
>> Problems of the Quran. All right. Moral
problems. Yes. All right. So then how is
it lawful? A married woman. Oh, but
Allah ordained it, so it's lawful. It's
okay. So then no matter what problem I
show you, you're going to say it's not a
problem because Allah w it. And if Allah
w it, then it must be true,
>> right? Well, I used historical problems,
too, like this uh thing about Joseph
telling someone he's going to be
crucified or something and crucifixion
didn't even exist.
Well, some of them just cope out or say,
"Man, maybe the word means something
else." As you say, they just
>> That's what I'm saying. That's why I
asked, "What would convince you the
Quran is not from God?" Because you just
confirmed what I said they're going to
do. See what you just told me,
>> right?
>> No, but the word may mean something
else. You don't know Arabic.
Maybe the Arabic means something else.
Okay. So they made up their mind. So why
are you trying to convince them?
>> Right. No, I I have to use the question
of what will convince you, right? You're
right.
>> Yeah. What kind of
>> issues
must the Quran have for you to doubt it?
You since you can tell them, but I can
show you one challenge from the Quran
that says this will prove it's not from
God. What is it? Surah chapter 4 verse
82 says, "Have they not pondered over
over the Quran with care?
Had it been from other than Allah, they
would find many contradictions."
So chapter 4 ayah 82 says the test to
show it's not from God find many
contradictions.
Now
>> right
>> if then you bring up contradictions say
well no it's not really a contradiction
because this word can mean this then
that means it's over. you're wasting
your time.
>> Okay. More power to you.
>> Thanks, man. Well, I had maybe one or
more one or two questions if you don't
mind. Uh, one is uh well, I use
frequently maybe the sometimes I'm on
offensive like attacking Quran. But
sometimes I'm on defense like how they
attack Bible and I have to defend.
Sometimes they go, well, Christ never
claimed to be God. I say, well, it's all
over John. But they say, well, John, you
know, is not as
>> all over Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
It's
>> right. Yeah, that that's what I wanted
to ask because it's not as um apparent
as it is in John. You know, it he claims
in other ways in other gospels,
>> but how is it apparent in John? Even in
John, he doesn't say I am God.
>> Well, like uh I and the father are one
before I don't know.
>> People going to explain it away. He
says, "Well, the disciples are one with
one another as Christ and the father
one." They'll even explain that away.
Where in the John could you point them
to convince them that Jesus claimed to
be God? Meaning
>> I am the first and the last. You know
this stuff.
>> Say it again.
>> I'll find the omega first and last.
These type of
>> That's Revelation.
>> Oh, that's Revelation.
>> Okay. So, that's what I'm saying. If you
go to John
What parts of John would you quote or
they admit okay yeah there Jesus
claiming to God but he didn't say it
>> well the problem is uh in the first uh
in the beginning they won't even accept
John as uh authentic as the other
gospels you know I wanted you
go as authentic say so wait you accept
Matthew Mark and Luke
>> when they all report that Jesus is the
son of God who has power to forgive sins
pour out the Holy Spirit who was killed
on the cross, was resurrected, and
ascended to heaven and reigns as Lord
over heaven and earth. That's in
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and Acts. It's not
just John. You You kidding me? They're
not going to accept that either.
>> Right. Right. So even if I go to Mark
and I go to Mark 14:61-62
which I'm going to read the context to
show you that the Jews understood that
Jesus was now claiming to be more than a
mere human but to be the equal to the
father sharing in his sovereignty and
dominion over all creation which they
considered to be blessings because they
took him to be just a Jewish man and
condemned them to die. they're going to
accept it. And the high priest stood up
in their midst and questioned Jesus,
saying, "You answer nothing? Why are
these men testifying against you?" But
he kept silent and did not answer.
Again, the high priest was questioning
him and said to him, "Are you the
Christ, the son of the blessed?" And
Jesus said, "I am." And you shall see
the son of man seating at the right hand
of the power and coming with the clouds
of heaven. So they they're going to
accept that Jesus is the son of man who
sits at the right hand of God in heaven
because God is in heaven. Of course,
they will cope out and say, "Well, that
doesn't make him God, does it?"
>> Wait, you mean someone sitting on the
throne with God coming on the clouds of
heaven doesn't make him God? So, you're
saying the Quran is full of shad because
the Quran says there is no one who
shares with Allah and his dominion over
the heaven and earth and Allah comes
with the clouds.
>> Right? That's a good one. So are you
saying the Quran is full of shad
>> because is really not
>> no but according to me
>> brother according to them the Quran says
Allah has no son or partner is dominion
>> right
>> chapter 17 11 chapter 25:2
so what do you mean this doesn't make
him god because it says he shares in the
dominion of the father because To sit at
the right hand of the power means he's
se seated in heaven. Where is Allah
above the throne? But Jesus says that's
where he's going to be at the right hand
of the power.
>> Right. Right.
>> And then he says he's the one who's
going to come with the clouds of heaven.
But according to the Quran, it's Allah
who will come with the clouds of heaven
and the angels.
Right.
>> Right.
Well, you know, as you said, it is just
more of a they won't accept if you if
they don't want to accept, nothing will
convince them because whatever you say,
they will say, "Well, that doesn't make
him go."
>> That's my whole point that it's not true
that you can't show Christ as God from
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and Acts because
Luke wrote Acts. You most definitely
can, and it's very explicit. It's not
implicit, which is why they condemned
him for blasphemy. You don't condemn a
person for blasphemy unless he's making
himself equal to God and rob robbing God
of his glory and unique status. So why
did they condemn him for blasphemy?
[clears throat]
Because he was
>> ascribing himself the prerogatives of
God and the unique glory and status of
God. That's why it says, look,
you've heard the blasphemy.
We don't need any more witnesses. He
deserves to die,
right? But that's not the only time they
said that. In Mark 2:es 1 to2, when he
sees a paralyzed man and he says, "Son,
your sins are forgiven." They go, "Why
does this fellow talk like this?
He is blaspheming." Who can forgive sins
but God alone?
And Jesus says, "I'm going to show you
that I have the power on earth to
forgive sins." Notice again, claiming to
be the son of man. Son of man that sits
at the right hand of power comes with
the clouds of heaven and the son of man
who forgives sins on earth here. Why
does this man speak that way? He's
blaspheing. Who can forgi for forgive
sins but God alone? But what did Jesus
say? I'm going to do a miracle. I'm
going to heal him so that you may know
that the son of man has authority on
earth to forgive sins. Do you notice
both at the beginning end of Mark?
Christ claims to be the son of man in
such a way that shows he's equal to God
and does what only God can do. And in
both instances, the Jews condemn him for
blasphemy.
>> Right. But again, it goes back to your
point, man. Like I say, well, uh, he
forgave sins, but then they say, well,
that he didn't say, "I forgive your
sins." He said, "Your sins are
forgiven."
>> No, it says, "So that you may know the
Son of Man has authority on earth to
forgive sins." What are you talking
about? Yes, he did.
>> All right.
What are you talking about, dude?
>> Right. Right. No, ironically enough, I
used something very similar to this. And
the the dude told me, "Well, Moses uh
split the sea. That's something only God
could do. No man can do." What does it
say? Splitting the sea is something only
God can do because God can enable his
agents to do miracles. But the Quran
itself agrees only Allah forgives sins.
Chapter 335.
>> Oh, that's right. I never never saw this
Allah alone
>> 3135.
>> Right.
>> Right. Right.
>> So no if then this is from Mark. I
didn't use John.
>> Thank you brother. That's all.
>> All right buddy. God bless you. I watch
my
>> you too man. Right. How do I contact you
more frequently? I don't want to join
streams all the time. Like I really tr I
really seek this truth of Christ. I
really do want to know how do I ask my
small questions here.
>> Well, if you send me an email and it's a
question
>> first check YouTube and the web, see if
it's already answered and if you have
serious questions, maybe I'll bring you
live. We'll see. We'll take it from
there.
>> Thanks, man. God bless you.
>> God bless you. Peace.